okay yeah stream is working let me share
it on the Li chest chat and then we'll
get started so I was going to do a ten
person Simon however there were a few
more people who joined so I'm just going
to accept everyone else it's gonna be 12
people let me share the stream in the
chat good luck everyone and we'll get
started 12 players playing 15 minutes
with a ten second increments just want
to make sure it's frames correctly it
looks decent
gonna mix up the openings today try and
get a different opening in every single
game it makes it more difficult for me
but hopefully more interesting for the
viewers and the players a4 is very
strange okay let's just play normally
this guy's just trying to mess with me
just continue playing normally
g6 some part of me wants to play h4
that's taking inspiration from that
the crazy guy going for h5 knight c6
this is going to be usually six and
knight c6 don't combine very well let's
just play d4 so one of my favorite
openings but should be five space love
b5 okay take that it's good it's just
continuing to mess with me while h6 is
actually sort of annoying so I'm gonna
play h6 myself Bishop e2 is very common
trap the pawn on e4 is a poisoned pawn
let me go for H five if he takes it all
probably just sack the exchange
so of course if might take a fork when a
for a check with one night's I'm trying
to remember the theory here I think
maybe just rookie one Bishop f1 if I
play d4 immediately he can probably take
on you for now let's play rook e1 Oh
game just started it's 35 Queen b6
pretty sure the move is Queen b3 usually
Queen b6 is played when the the c8
bishop can develop to f5
there would be more annoying things but
here if Queen b3 see for Queen c2 I'm
pretty pretty comfortable why don't you
contact someone of leech s so that you
twitch session will be announced on the
front page yeah so from my understanding
there's some blog section on me chess
which says you have to like have a
consistent stream for a little bit
before it can be featured on the front
page so I'm gonna contact them soon but
I've only been streaming for a week so
I'm still kind of getting used to the
whole twitch environments and then
eventually I'm gonna try and set like a
regular schedule to for twitch streams
so people will know ahead of time but
thanks more Iran for the question lady
for I see we have a comment in the
twitch chat now is they following yo you
gotta let u ones you were getting that
sentence doesn't make any sense
I see 13 people are watching so there's
more than one viewer maybe it was an old
comment though let's put this [ __ ]
before just respond to my Ron in case he
missed my response little contact each I
played d3 mmm I don't want to go into
like mainline let's play the Cambridge
Springs my bg7 it's fun opening you did
hear me okay that's good yeah for
whoever is watching if you have comments
or questions feel free to to put them in
the cyma which chat so I'll be watching
both play d5 let's go for some Benoni I
really want to play Bishop say got seven
here but probably just doesn't work
Knight g5 Bishop take t1 Bishop take F
seven also probably doesn't work I mean
I have like Queen D 5 IV 5 25 if he
takes 25 I take on r7
yeah this line is uh usually pretty fun
for black g4 let's tuck the bishop away
Bishop f5 is feels a little bit awkward
I kind of want to play h6 and just shut
down his uh story Bishop let's do that
okay let's have some fun let's play this
leaning it's a very old opening I used
to play in tournaments had a decent
score with f6
Queen d5 f 2g v Queen f7 King d7 mmm she
don't see a clear one here I'm just
gonna take on d6 open the e-file which
openings do you normally recommend for
me I'm a beginner that normally plays
Queen's pawn King's pawn and Roy Lopez I
also know what stuff like fork pain
deflections yeah Ava player nine nine
eight it sounds like at your stage
openings are probably not the most
important area of the game to focus on
they are easy to study but for most
players I've seen most chess games and
facts will be determined in the middle
game or endgame so if you have like time
and energy to study chess I would
recommend save the openings for later
and and focus more on like kind of
tactics middle game strategy look at
like high level high level games so I
think Oh openings are probably a bit
overrated for first study at least at
the kind of lower levels they do become
more relevant at the higher levels
though rook e1 runs into Bishop f5
that's very key one
I will say though that if you are
looking to study openings stick to like
one rapper tour don't try and play
everything so sounds like if you're
playing King's pawn and Queens pawn pick
one try and learn it well because a lot
of opening or like the trick to becoming
good at like a certain opening is
getting a lot of experience especially
game experience so I hope that answer
helps
let's play Queen c2 preventing Bishop f5
preparing Sandra p1v for stuff and this
guy just started like b3
let's see I'll play Queen h4 g3 start
with rook b8 throw in that move with not
too many consequences
I'm just gonna start throwing pieces at
the queenside something should work
there
meow 4 1 1 4 2 1 4 I'll have to look at
that game and see if I'm totally playing
horrible moves here it might be possible
it's like this guy just dropped upon
might be too greedy if I'll take it
yeah me now unfortunately I don't like
to be mean and say horrible moves but
they haven't been the best moves it's
however I like I'm still not winning to
travel a trip trivially I do have to
play some accurate moves to convert this
I'm just going to keep throwing pieces
let's play d5 all these games I still
have to complete developments
mmm I see a very tricky idea
let's play Queen c5 see what he does I'm
up upon here I might as well just trade
Queens take on c3 I'll hold on to the
bishop hair
Oh King b8 so the point was if pawn take
Queen I have 97 mates nice job for
seeing that me out unfortunate King b8
runs into me than to Queenie saddened
so yeah I mean sometimes games like that
happen if you know 4 to 1 4 if you're
playing someone much higher than your
level I mean you're kind of expected to
have a game like that what you want to
do is kind of look back at the game and
try and figure out where you could have
improved and I think it was early on you
lost material rights if we go back oops
I don't know what just happened there
let me just point out this one thing
okay Lee chest is not letting me go back
but me out if you want to stick around
afterwards I can show you and give you
some suggestions where to improve
unfortunately I still have a lot more
games to deal with this guy wants to win
the d5 pawn he's attacking at four times
c4 was actually a very powerful looking
move because it cuts off my bishop as
well
he's unrated and classical oh here's a
high foots rating though I have to be
careful with this guy
it's not the end of the world if I lose
d5 but it's not not exactly Pleasant
so probably the best step is to
counter-attack d4 alright to counter
taxi 492 hope for some counter play
let's just go for trades there and this
guy being annoying actually a6 is very
annoying because if I played b6 Bishop
e5 rook c8 95 play Queen b6 looks decent
it might take to you five I'm actually
in a lot of trouble here I forgot my
bishop is hanging on g5 after I move
like Knight takes c3 if I take on c4 he
takes on c4 doesn't work at all that's
why this keeps things defended keeps
things complicated
it's Castle this guy wants to do some
minority attack with b5 coming I think
the one issue for him is a c4 square
might as well put in right there let's
fight for for some center with c5
mm-hmm
that's on my h6 pawn I guess scared uh
scared him away from Castle kingside now
he castles queenside I think it's still
possible for me to generate some kind of
attack there I'm gonna try and play a
bit quicker and in games that I can I
may have just blundered Bishop before
they're entirely sure
not entirely sure why the game isn't
switching either isn't maybe it's
opponents move on the on every board at
Bishop d3 didn't really accomplish much
there 984 Wow
that's why he played h4 to stop Queen h4
check it's incredible the h4 it was just
such a strange move now there there's
one move that comes to mind here tonight
f4 with the idea that if Bishop take a
fork when a5 check but nine to four
Queenie for finding my knife threatening
mates everything's hanging but I haven't
I take to e3 if Queen take to iii-v she
think neither for works I take T three
solves everything
after Queen e4
which I might not be losing anything
Bishop a6 it should take a bishop take
f1 and I think it's all me move so in
this type of structured night is best
time z6 almost always speaking of g6 if
I win the d6 pawn it looks very risky
because I have b2 hanging but I might as
well go for it
I mean yeah this game black has a great
lead and development but it's still
going to take work to prove it it's
Castle at four it's typically good
that's c4 so I guess this guy wants its
planning some work a one idea but
actually the rook is tied down to the C
pawn so I think I somehow escaped that
take with the rook or the pawn stay with
the rook
and he wants to take on you for and some
some issues on this a6f one diagonal
let's play e5 wow this guy is being
super aggressive
might as well take it
he might go for h6 but I think I'll
survive
yeah so Queen a4 check
I should just win a piece Knight c3 so
he didn't capture anything he is
attacking my bishop I'm g5 so what I
take on c3 he takes on g5 I could take
on c4 and he his ideas at Bishop takes
c3 at the very end I think I have to
take on c3 first I might have 94th to
follow let's take this yeah 94
check the Queen's offend the Fon
I apologize for those who are commenting
in twitch I haven't been able to look at
the chat because I still have I still
have 11 games going I only won one game
so far I'll try and answer questions
later once I have some some down time
okay so he's attacking both pawns both
of which I don't think I really care
about let's play Queen f3 this just
looks like a very fun attack
I thought I want a piece in this game
but I guess not maybe you just went upon
let's play let's play this
mf5 looks a little bit risky with my
bishop still on a - I guess he wants to
win c3 so Knight g5 Bishop takes c3
rookie 7 I'm definitely gonna get some
counter play I don't it's enough but
we'll see like g5
oh that's a pin my bishop has pinned to
my queen let's play I 5 that's almost
most problems mm-hmm I think f3 here
looks very strong
he plays g3 then I have work h6h for g5
man this guy f6 this is very solid
didn't I have a knight ok uh yeah c3
just start playing quicker
your Simon are so late for europeans I
apologize to those in Europe if I do
like set a regular schedule I'll
probably ask for some some feedback so
if you guys have any like preferred
times I do these types of Simoes and
streams let me know I'm thinking like
one like afternoon stream in one late
night stream I'm on I'm on Chicago time
so that would satisfy a lot of people
maybe still not that Europeans let's
actually take with the bishop night will
be strong free pawn
this is going to be a very long game
this is a great positional game so far
but it still takes work let's go for
some attack Oh Queen takes e3 kind of
forgot about that
let's not Queen trade let's do this it's
something and this guy with his annoying
moves
I can play trucks eh should be no issue
we can also play 95 let's take that
I have to take with king
- I lose a pawn oh my gosh lost upon but
I got the H file it's not good though
Queenie -
I take okay let's take if he takes with
pawn I take on you seven
I don't know how to deal with the
situation I take the Queen he takes rook
c7 I'm losing a pawn in the end
b5 I don't think works to move the
night's yeah why not bring the Knight to
g6 Bishop b2 King d2 Queen 85 check it's
got to be good
I could take on u7 i could play Knight
g5 let's take your first just c3 okay
I'll play c3 I'll shut out the bishop
and then have fun on the Kings side
this game's gonna get pretty sharp do I
have rocky eights rookie eights
it looks promising
I don't have it's winning but feels like
a move he could have missed
this might as well increase the pressure
it's all these moves increasing the
pressure rook hitch one at rook F eights
good response
I could play rook e1 he takes he takes
with the a rook don't think that quite
works
my work on any one is hanging I might as
well move it to safety some somehow play
rugby one
I'm gonna play rook a flan problem is
like the root gets attacked on a lot of
squares let's play Bishop III yeah I'm
gonna have to move much much faster but
the positions are getting difficult
let's do this
this is around where lenders will begin
to happen but try and minimize on as
best as possible
Oh No Queen b6 is coming at least that
guy's low on time too
free pawn
or Bishop d6 I'm just gonna go for the
queenside attack hope it works
so I've won three games already not sure
what the other two games were I remember
the first one I want it's still a lot
more to go let's do this taxi for pawn
Thank You chess iteration for
complimenting the Queen c5 move it's
probably the move of the day so far
let's take the rook
he's attacking my rook I should move
this play solid they take on d4 this
works
come up upon this game this game is
gonna be very long though I don't think
there's anything to clear-cut here yeah
my Knights are controlling the whole
back rank which is looking good this
move looks very strong Queen b5 might
just be mating there
ninety-seven
could take the rook on a one that's
probably simplest
so I think I'm I'm better in most of
these games but it's gonna come down to
time so most of these games I just have
a minute left and it's going to be it's
going to require playing a bunch of
quick moves and this position is very
complex hmm might as well attack stuff
I'm happy I put the ten second
increments giving me more time let's
take care of try and simplify
it's another very complex position
oh this should be very close to winning
for me it's just a matter of time I
think I can take here a lot of things
are hanging though I take the pawn first
let's take the rook
okay that was a pawn it's on now I'm
winning a piece so much stuff to take I
think I have Queen e6 check though 26
King f8 and that doesn't work if I take
I could take on g6 take on g6 not nice
Bishop okay let's take here if he takes
on that phone I take on g6 that loses b1
let's play rook c1 first forgot about
you sixer hey this ending should be
winning Queen trade I think I'm happy
with mmm there's no time
how do I stop that pawn throwing a check
while this is just moving quickly in
gaining time where's my mate let's throw
in another check
I just hung a rook that was bad
oh you didn't see it okay hit Bishop
takes you on God probably have to go
suck a knight in that game
oh that's uh needs
I take
let's take there hope for the best
thank you fuel mule
best best username name that I've seen
in a while
let's not get mated
so I've won five games seven games still
going a lot of these I can't really
spend much time at all just have to
plant instincts this game is actually
really interesting I might still have
some winning chances
hmmm that's annoying let's do this
I have chances in this game to outside
past a pawn
I don't know why I did what I'm doing
here
oh no I flagged that position well Don
whoever that was just gotta keep moving
quickly
okay seven wins one loss and he wants to
win the Jeep on I'll win his Jeep on
okay so I think the plan is to convert
the positions I'm winning and then deal
with the positions which aren't so clear
like this game it's just a matter of
time I just have three games going this
game is gonna be winning this games one
of the trickier ones this could take a
long time to win but I would think it
should be eventually winning this game
is gonna be the trickiest to win I might
even have to risk losing if I want to
win this game set up a small trick here
and he fell for it yeah he should have
played Queen da check keep going for
checks without allowing the Queen trade
okay so two of these games are
completely winning and then one game
this game not so clear but I have
chances I should have chances best
username no I meant fuel mule it's a
great name jazzy Chester
it's decent username
okay I'm gonna gain time by just moving
around and then I should finish off the
other games so I can focus solely on
that game
pretty sure I can get away with King t3
so king g3 can take me three a five
there's no way he's stopping that a pond
okay nice game
run till tomorrow now it's finally time
to read some of the twitch twitch
comments mr. Wallace is feeling an
opening who's my favorite player and why
from of a player 9 9 8 that's actually a
tough question
favorite player I mean I really admire
Karpov like the old car ball games where
he just grinds down his opponent
positionally are are fun to look at
I mean modern-day players from a
personality standpoint I would have to
say Levon Aronian like one of the nicest
GM's that I've I've ever met
I think this a plan is queening okay
we're just about to wrap up
hello talent Factory if you're still
watching I know you sent that comment
one time ago yo yeah so meow I'll
probably be most likely to stream on the
weekends I just have to calculate this
one sec a7 I could just play Q me to
keep things simple so yeah if you're
looking for like these types of streams
and simultaeously run like rebuilding my
website and then I'll probably post some
kind of like Google Calendar or kind of
set schedule for weekly streams and
smiles but that's still kind of up in
the air all right well thank you
everyone for for playing with Simon
Congrats to the one winner I forgot who
it was I think was Louis wasn't Louis
Sheila Dada shilada something see if I
can find this game because this game
that I flagged I have to look back at
the video but I think I was very close
to playing the move with my time ran out
but sometimes this is a best strategy if
you're playing against someone who's
playing a bunch of games at once just
keep it keep it a long game and keep it
kind of complicated
yeah I think I was about to take on on
g5 here it still would take a lot of
work to win this position but yeah this
slight squared Bishop defending the d3
pawn is it's very annoying probably the
best approach your light is like take
take and then get some activity final
now King g6
my King has to find some square but
still take work for sure
yeah I don't actually see a clear win
here well nice job let's go back I think
I could have easily lost a lot more
games given the time situation a lot of
them this game against fuel mule this
was one of the more interesting games I
think he was out playing me at some
points with Knight b6
yeah the c-4 move just very powerful
blocking my bishop and attacking the
pawn four times but I think I managed to
keep it complicated despite the fact
Black was probably just better maybe I
fight was a bit too ambitious
sometimes a position like this huge like
as black you just want to to make sure
everything's defended I think I five
just created more weaknesses I'm not
entirely sure what the alternative is
here
maybe you move like rook d8 it's a very
tense position
and yeah this position it was crazy like
I wanted to play b1 or rook d1 but the
problem was that I move like Queen c2
hits the rook and Bishop rook f1 I mean
it's not the prettiest move but okay
somehow somehow this transpired into a
good position for whites yeah I think at
this point probably h6 was uh maybe the
final mistake it was weakening g6 and I
mean it led to a position where just so
many things were were attacked like the
bishop the rook the the pawn was a under
constant pressure the C pawn was under
constant pressure so maybe there's a
better move than h6 here not entirely
sure what that would be
maybe Queen C to get the C pawn rolling
or just some centralizing move like
Queen g4 definitely an interesting game
okay I think I'm gonna take a break
hello Bobby Fischer actually hello Bobby
how's that but Celsius maybe fact
exchange okay by Celsius thanks to
everyone who's watching who watched the
stream I'm gonna try and do more of this
in the future I think this was a lot for
today
nice imma light a Cal OTT of energy if
anyone has like suggestions for other
types of streams or you want questions
answered feel free message me on me
chess or or even twitch I think there's
some way to message someone on Twitch
and I will be back in the future for for
more content like this
adios